your host Daniel you are and I'm
delighted to be joined by Zach wood from
Sony Santa Monica doin sir I'm doing
great you are a CD producer on a whole
comb which is a game that I believe is
being developed by the guy's a honey
slug or in London as I yeah it's
actually a collaboration between honey
slug and Richard ha who's the art
director artist yeah excellent nice
elaboration and this got a revealed last
year at e3 and for folks who don't know
much about this game and it's let to be
honest it is a type of game that is
difficult to put a cross and without
having played it and what exactly is a
whole come well like you said it's kind
of a hard game to describe which is why
shows like this are awesome because
people can pick it up and play it and
experiencing but i would say at its core
it's about exploration it's i think what
makes it unique is that it's a it's a
game that doesn't really tell you or
hold your hand in terms of what you're
supposed to do but the worlds are very
reactive to whatever you're doing and so
the game goals and activities sort of
get revealed to the player over time and
so what i want i first fell in love with
this game was that I knew that the the
what your character's name is known as
the long moversmovers which is a
wonderful mighty boosh referent actly
which i'm not sure if that ever even
aired over here in north america yeah
and but well yeah we're looking at the
gameplay now we just kind of try and
explain to folks at home what's going on
yeah so well one thing to point out is
that there are over sixteen different
worlds and all the worlds are very
different from one another this is the
forest plateau so what he had just done
was under underneath the plateau there's
this lamb fruit tree and the characters
there are these gibbehhhhh's they sort
of like monkey looking creatures like to
pick those up and pester other animals
with it right so he went down there
pollinate the tree I'm brought to give
us up to the top and now they're
throwing it at the Barbarossa which is
the sort of a boss battle raava but in a
very hohokam way yeah because nothing in
this game is stressful you can't die you
can't really fail
I've heard of being called the most read
the most relaxing game at e3 I believe
you'll take that will happily take that
and what I like about it as well as
obviously you've got their primary
objectives in each level you've got
there's also sort of secondary stuff
that you don't necessarily need but
there's all kinds of stuff and that's
the thing it's like yes every world has
a thing like a primary activity but
there's also like everything reacts you
in some way shape or form and there's
all kinds of secrets and hidden elements
all over the game it seems like a game
that's been created almost like an
experience just to create discovery like
it's a wonderful game to just sit down
with relax wit for a while yeah I know
it's challenging but not in a sort of a
in a fast thumbs kind of way just in a
kind of a cognitive way exactly it was
it was definitely specifically designed
to be not stressful and you know
non-traditional and you know a game
that's just enjoyable and relaxing to
play so you mentioned it there are
different worlds as well yeah how many
different worlds are we looking at and
how long is each one sort of generally
take I mean it kind of depends on how
the player wants to play because you
know it's really kind of up to them how
they want to experience the game it's
also really nonlinear so all these
worlds are not gated by your progress
like you don't have to complete the
space to move on to the next one when
you put up the game for the first time
you can travel anywhere do anything very
freeform in that way so this is an
example of a hallway space that connects
other worlds together so he's got two
other spaces that he could travel to but
even these spaces are kind of
interactive you know and well how about
it I don't know if this sounds rude
octave or not but it looks like a very
Sony game like you guys have a lot of
these like a very visually confident
striking and like relaxing experiences
it is that there's that sort of what the
influence of the gentlemen at Sony santa
monica is yeah I think so I mean I also
think we're just we're really drawn to
like boundary-pushing super creative
beautiful games that's just kind of what
drives
and you know I think we're also trying
to like kind of you know change the
perception of what a video game is and
yeah be right because it's like people
hear about what I do for a living and
like oh you must work on shooters or
something else and it's like going to
know there's all this other stuff and
other games that have all kinds of
different experiences right and so this
is one of them you know and it's just we
were drawn to this this game show I
think it was IGF back in 2010 the
developer was showing it there and we
were just immediately drawn to it like
oh my god this is beautiful and amazing
and it's really just fun to kind of
cruise around you know so even though
there are you know goals and activities
like if you never figured any of that
stuff out it would still be a fun game
yeah just to play around with I've seen
it shown at a bunch of I think perhaps
when it was back when it was before we
signed on actually yeah I post IGF I've
seen it a lot of very trade shows and
it's one of these games it's almost like
just waiting for it to come out we're
actually quite close to a coming out now
we are at the end of this summer finally
have a release date yeah August twelfth
and it's coming out for ps4 ps3 and PS
Vita cross by its cool so you buy one
you get them all and it supports cross
saves you can save it resumed on any
platform awesome Adrian on Twitter and
is asking oh he was actually asking was
this beautiful for classified yes okay
yeah you just jumped in there yeah
taking my questions away from me yeah
the other interesting thing about this
game is that we're we're collaborating
with a record label which is kind of a
different a different thing okay so
ghost international we're working with
on the soundtrack and so every track in
every world is unique and they're all
artists on the ghostly label so it's
artists like Tycho Ben Benjamin shigeto
mishneh which has been a really really
amazing experience and we got there
because we first started talking to the
team about what the music might sound
like in the game they shared their
playlists and it just so happened that a
lot of the musicians they were listening
to when they were coming up with ideas
yeah happen to be on the go see label so
we're like well we should we should go
talk to ghostly yeah and so we did that
and we've been working with them and
it's been awesome what I what I'm
looking at this one when I
see it is it reminds me a lot of when I
how I used to play locoroco which was
very much a you know you could die but
it wasn't really much of a challenge but
it didn't negate from the experience it
was very much about sort of having fun
with the world absolutely so what's
going on here because this actually
looks really different to what we were
looking up completely different right
and that's kind of a good example how
they all look and feel very different so
this is the guano factory okay and so
these characters here are that that's on
the players backer like harvesters and
so they're harvesting this liquid now
they're being chased to it but they're
harvesting this liquid that that the
drones are sort of dropping in the sky
and then they fill up their tanks which
are part of their bodies and then you
drop them off in this big huge tank and
you need to fill it up with liquid and
that's kind of the primary thing that's
going on here you're basically trying to
get the factory up and running again by
helping the workers fill up the van full
of liquid it's all part of the the rich
narrative of hohokam is there is there a
is there a wider university or trying to
allude to or is it all very much this is
our our place s just yeah yeah there
isn't really like a story connecting the
spaces together they all kind of live on
their own and the players free to
experience them however he wants you
know I'm very very boring question to
ask for a bunch of folks in the child of
past so i might have to do it is there
any multiplayer this seems to be like no
I began you would play all right it's a
very singular experience yet and Martin
case is asked and how long are each
level is each level I mean it kind of
varies depending on how you how you play
what we found is that it's actually a
pretty long game in recent play test we
found that people in like a couple of
hours we're only really completing about
three or four spaces and they're 16 so
no long enough can't do the math there
you go and do you expect this the type
of game that people are going to get
more you are going to play more on the
PlayStation Vita or do you feel like
this is a game that folks are going to
sit down and their couches and enjoy at
home on a sitting room hard to say i
mean i like the home experience because
the sound design and the music is
amazing and they've in the end they've
done a lot of stuff with five months so
if you've got a great sound system like
it'll it'll it'll make a big difference
but there's also input changes that
we've done so on the on the ps4
controller on the touchpad you can
actually draw with the lung mover go
catch it and kind of draw around and it
records what you're doing and he's doing
it right there and it'll just playback
whatever it was that you drew excellent
it's just another way to be expressive
because the character itself is very
expressive yeah in the way that it moves
around the world the light bar changes
with the color of the of the lung mover
and also we're using the speakers to
enhance some of the audio in the game
what you got somebody seem to be very
proactive about at picking up indie
games I think as a playstation 4 owner
it's been very beneficial that's been
between like I'm a fan of indie games as
well but like just in between those big
tenfold releases that there's a lot of
stuff there to keep you occupied like
yeah i was playing transistor two weeks
ago when it's probably best game i
played this year that's fantastic exam
is that it I don't know what level
you're on there is a part of your day
today but it's within the culture of
Sony is that very much a yeah I mean I
think you probably saw some of that the
press conference yeah so Sony you know
as a whole is really embracing indie
development really creative beautiful
different kind of boundary pushing games
and I think you know for Santa Monica
studio we're kind of known for that
you know games like flower and sound
shapes which I worked on the unfinished
Swan these are the kinds of games that
inspire us so yeah we just we just love
them a lot so this is kind of another
one of those I'm is the is the idea in
recent months I suppose it like that the
result has become this expectation
that's lots of these types of games
become available for the PlayStation
Vita and the fact you guys are doing it
on cross fly as well and just seemed
like it it almost seems like it benefits
to consumers so much don't know how
could benefit you guys yeah when you're
doing that is is the onus on that to
ensure that people are experienced in
the PlayStation Vita or is it that you
think the people who own playstation 4
zone beaters or that they might like
what's the what's the what's the big
reason behind having that system and the
fact you guys have actually used it so
frequently the PS Vita yeah the cross by
specifically well i think i think the PS
Vita is an amazing device you know and i
think it's also trying to continue to
drive the message about how great of a
piece of hardware in it yeah that's part
of it but the other thing is it just
makes sense you know a lot of these
games are easier to to do cross platform
and so we're going to do that you know
whether it's extending the audience of
people who may have PS Vita and maybe
not have ps4 or the convenience factor
of being able to you know save your game
on ps4 and pick it up and resume on Vita
that's a pretty awesome thing right yeah
i'm i'm so used to cross buying cross
save now that I get really bummed when
it doesn't think this order right it's
just so cool so it's all those things I
think rolled into one yeah and also just
the Vita's screen is just gorgeous yeah
and this game it looks amazing on it I'm
all right in saying that this is also
coming in on playstation 3 still yeah as
well yeah yeah cuz you guys have been
involved you did you pick this up with
the last year pretty but the europe so
your involvement with this sony's
involvement with this was it with hella
how long has that been for years okay
yeah yeah so was it was it always the
case cuz so there been so many games
that I we knew were coming in on
PlayStation 3 last year yeah and that
they've all now
as if not cross by but at least coming
out on playstation 4 Evita was her own
deal with always our plans to have this
like sab ki nothing yeah and so for the
folks at home lastly at holcomb when is
it available August twelfth and how much
they're gonna cost them we don't have a
price yet we haven't in that we haven't
announced the price yet cool alright I'm
soon thank you very much like wood I'm
take pleasure thank you very much very
much coming in Sean Hong Kong